c'est un lendemain de fête que personne
ne pouvait imaginer une trentaine d'amis
de longue date s'étaient réunis en forêt
et en musique un rassemblement autorisé
par le maire de savigny le sec mais dans
la soirée un inconnu de 21 ans s'est
jointe au groupe apparemment inoffensifs
mais dans les vapes et silencieux ce
n'est qu'au matin vers 10 heures qu'il a
volé un véhicule et a démarré en
direction des quelques jeunes endormi
sous leurs tentes
les jeunes étaient couchés et ces
personnes a pris une voiture d'un des
jeunes et commencé sa course folle ici
féliciter insectes oil de tantièmes un
jeune homme juste à côté à rouler dessus
le bilan fait état de cinq blessés dont
deux graves qui ont été évacués en
hélicoptère
le conducteur a pris la fuite et a été
interpellé dix kilomètres plus loin près
de dijon après un nouvel accident
il s'est débattu et a blessé trois
gendarmes lors de son arrestation selon
le parquet ce jeune homme originaire de
haute marne n'avait pas de casier
judiciaire mais des antécédents
psychiatriques
c'est une personne enfin qui avait l'air
totalement dans les vapes en fait
incohérente qui n'alignait pas deux mots
voilà donc impossible de tenir une
conversation avec elle donc voilà où on
s'est dit bon c'est peut-être une
personne qui est venue avec un de nos
amis on sait pas on la connaît pas on
laisse couler on est on allé on était
fatigués on allait se coucher quoi
l'individu n'étant pas en état de
supporter une garde à vue ce jeudi il a
été hospitalisé
des prélèvements sanguins ont été
effectués les enquêteurs espèrent
pouvoir l'interroger dès demain matin
pour en savoir plus sur les
circonstances de son acte